the changes to playstation plus have
been revealed and breath of the wild 2
has been pushed back let's talk about it
following a series of leaks and rumors
playstation has officially unveiled the
next generation of playstation plus as
expected the relaunch of the playstation
subscription service will combine the
perks of playstation plus and
playstation now when the subscription
launches in june it will be available in
three separate tiers essential extra and
premium the standard playstation plus
subscription will be rebranded to
playstation plus essential and despite
the new name it's functionally the same
service playstation plus extra will cost
15 per month or 100 per year and feature
up to 400 playstation 4 and playstation
5 games sony's description of the extra
tier is a bit vague but subscribers will
be able to download the games in the
library to play on their console it'll
include both first party and third-party
games and considering the number of
games in this tier it sounds pretty much
like a combination of playstation plus
and playstation now current playstation
now subscribers will be converted to a
playstation plus extra subscription at
launch the most expensive of the bunch
playstation plus premium will feature up
to 340 additional games versus the extra
tier the premium plan will cost 18
dollars per month or 120 dollars per
year this tier's additional games appear
to be largely focused on playstation's
back catalog with original playstation
ps2 ps3 and psp games being available to
play ps3 games will be locked to cloud
streaming though but at least some of
the other backwards compatible classics
will be downloadable the premium tier
comes with a couple other perks too
including limited time game trials and
cloud streaming on pc all three
subscription tiers will be available on
playstation 4 and 5 though playstation 5
users will get access to more games for
months rumors of these changes were
looked at by many as playstation's way
to compete with xbox game pass however
with a lack of first-party games
releasing to sony's service on day one
this option isn't quite what fans were
waiting for playstation boss jim ryan
explained to games industry.biz why the
company didn't take this approach and
said quote we feel if we were to do that
with the games we make at playstation
studios that virtuous cycle will be
broken the level of investment that we
need to make in our studios would not be
possible and we think the knock-on
effect on the quality of the games that
we make would not be something that
gamers want so don't expect to get the
next god of war via playstation plus on
release day however this may not always
be the case ryan went on to say that
playstation is not strictly committed to
this it could turn around and change its
stance at any moment based on market
trends and other factors
now switching gears to the makers of the
switch nintendo has announced that the
sequel to breath of the wild will not
launch on time in 2022 and instead it's
been delayed to spring of 2023
according to the series producer the
delay was necessary to make the game's
experience something quote special for
players breath of the wild was a launch
title for the switch in 2017 and it went
on to sell 25.8 million copies worldwide
as of december 31st 2021 making it one
of the best selling switch games ever
and it's truly the gift that keeps on
giving our very own max blumenthal has
tons of videos revealing things you
didn't know about breath of the wild so
make sure to check those out when you
can so let me know on a scale of one to
ten how bummed you are that breath of
the wild two got pushed back i'm around
a two because this gives me more time to
actually beat eldon ring yes i'm still
talking about making my way through that
game it's very long and i'm taking my
sweet time
see you tomorrow
[Music]